it's been a minute it's it's been a
minute
how was well how was Ireland
[__] amazing
first of all what a country what a
country just just the people
are the greatest people yep the
landscape is just stunning
um I am awesome at driving on the
left-hand side of the road really better
than on the right side yeah no no no I'm
better than right but uh that tracks
does it well you're always talking about
how your brain is like opposite oh you
think about things differently I agree
well yeah first of all I like the
puttering engine of a diesel engine I
was like this is cool this this car
doesn't uh well just it's not a golf
cart like uh not like a hundred thousand
dollar golf cart like we drive but um
which is a superior machine I will I
will admit once I got back in I was like
this is better but I was having fun kind
of puttering around like in a diesel you
know half electric half diesel I think
it was but forever before the gas went
down
everywhere
I went
people
[__] love Sunny yeah it was so
heartwarming and refreshing and people
were genuinely excited you know we did
at one point we drove around the Ring of
Barrow which is in the southwest
corner of the island so it's like down
in Western Cork and what a drive just
just stunning View and we stopped at
this place called Helen's bar which was
really not nothing was near it
and they were like how the [__] did you
find this place what are you doing here
and but it was also like I guess
everyone has television but but it
seemed like a place that wouldn't have
television you know one of those towns
that had like five people in it but they
all watched as Glenn and I were just we
saw each other in the parking lot there
and as we were walking up I for some
reason I don't know why I mentioned to
him that I had finally seen the Banshees
of in a Sharon oh you have not seen yet
and right it's kind of exactly what
you're talking about yeah where there's
just this island and it was in what 1923
in the movie and there's really nothing
to do except a little bit of work here
or there and then you just go to the pub
every day at three o'clock four o'clock
and just get hammered what are you
talking about I was in Ireland for 10
days everyone there
is so wonderful about the show and loves
the show and uh I have I just loved
driving on the opposite side of the road
it was just like such a fun challenge I
feel like my brain like clicked into it
I did not like it at first the first
drive out there was Harry but by the
tenth day I was like get me in the left
side of this car my first three days I
kept walking to the wrong like the
passenger side to get in the car oh my
gosh [__] I gotta go around yeah but
then by the end I was zipping around
that thing loving every second of it I
don't think I've ever I drove on the
left side of the highway up here today
just because I missed it yeah yeah
that's fun yeah just dodging that's fun
no that was people were pissed
[Music]
Megan Megan Megan welcome back
I missed you guys great to see you holy
cow yeah here I am it seems like it's
been weeks and weeks and weeks really
you guys recorded things in like the one
week I was out of town so
some sometimes we do these things weeks
apart and sometimes we do like three
days in a row yeah because we we have to
I think it's important for people to
know that actually in case we bring
something back up in case you know
something from an episode that we talked
about comes back or something I mean an
episode of the podcast comes back up and
we're like oh yeah last week blah blah
blah and it's something that right you
know we posted four weeks ago or
something in fact the one that's gonna
air on Monday or they probably will
listen they will have already seen this
one but the Dennis system one we
actually recorded before the last two
that air just because we had to just
schedule a schedule so we all got lives
here
um but yeah it was uh it was fun I did a
little road trip went out to Denver and
back uh and it was really fun just me
and the dog just hitting the wide open
road didn't get murdered yeah just
driving around with a dog let me tell
you something that Ireland has gotten
right that that our country has gotten
wrong every time you
and you're not like and there's the
McDonald's and there's the Walmart and
there's the Starbucks like
we've destroyed our our small towns that
are small businesses and our beautiful
landscape with the mollification of
America I'm running
residence in 2024 I'm announcing it
right here oh my God I would hate to be
present
that would be awful guys wouldn't that
suck how
much
it's on fire
yeah I missed you guys I'm happy I'm
happy to be here and chat I'm excited to
hang out that's very sweet I'm excited
as well now how many cups of coffee have
you had you seemed pretty coffee though
yeah I mean always but no more than
usual by this point just in a good mood
I'm just in a great mood I'm just in a
good mood yeah that's weird because I
was driving here thinking like
not that I'm in a bad mood I'm actually
not I'm in a good mood I just was like
usually I'm driving over and I'm
thinking like oh you know what I want to
talk about this like I bet you know I
have got something on my mind something
that you know irritated me or something
Jesus is good but he got an irritation
yeah it's usually an irritation and
about sometimes it's a you know
something that was awesome and I was
just driving over and I was like I got I
I don't know man
yeah that's okay it's good but yeah I
guess that's the weather's good you know
it's not good for the podcast but well
no I agree it's not good for the podcast
you know I think Rob's right it's better
when we got something to argue about
some kind of fighting yeah did that all
stay in yeah you don't watch the podcast
that is what I'm learning no yeah I mean
how much of a narcissist I mean who's
gonna sit back and watch the podcast
quality control quality control I trust
Megan
and Mara and our entire team really I
mean
um well that's foolish because you know
because you're coming off terrible
coming off like a real douche
um
I sometimes enjoy you know I'll give
like a note or two but hardly any you do
do a very good job every time thank you
Charlie I appreciate it yeah I don't
know often get a chance to watch them
before we we post them uh yeah try to
but I don't run in a little behind
sometimes but I watch all of them I
watch all the ones when when you when I
wasn't here and I appreciated like I
mean I definitely did leave in all the
conversations about uh bands and your
diets and yeah all the fights amino
acids and all that me gaslighting Glenn
yeah yeah
um no I I left all those uh mostly
because I wanted people to miss me
getting you guys back on track so it was
a strategy on my part well we noticed
that there was an episode where you
weren't there and then all of a sudden
Maura was there and we weren't sure
exactly why and we we did ask that we're
literally certain we that it was yeah
all right yeah
it's like having a like having a
substitute teacher who didn't yeah
somebody actually commented it was like
a substitute teacher who wasn't told
that she had the worst class in school
told she had the worst class in school
oh my God weren't you was it I remember
just being brutal brutal it's a
substitute I feel bad actually I think I
feel bad because I mean because that
person looked like they were 45 years
old and most likely they were 32. way
younger yeah 21 yeah right out of school
making ten dollars an hour yeah and
making nothing just getting abused yeah
also but
there does seem like I get it from the
kids perspective right which is like
hang on a second you know the deal is I
gotta come in the class I got I can't be
home with my Nintendo I gotta come in I
gotta I gotta sit and I gotta listen to
this teacher I gotta learn [__] now if
that teacher bails on the deal
don't slap in a new person okay I am
committed to this one this eighth grade
teacher all year long you're gonna stick
a someone else in uh-uh no and so you
know you gotta you gotta rip them a
little do you they get it do you think
that the kids are mean to the substitute
out of loyalty to the original teacher
just just out of just out of like well
this is a raw deal right it should be
like if the teacher's sick if I gotta be
school's out you know it's like a snow
day it's like you know you're always
looking for your boundaries as a as a
kid and you're looking to see if you can
where's the moment where's the point of
weakness and like with Maura it was
clear that there was no point of
weakness we tried we came at her but she
kept putting she kept shutting it down
she was like the she was like that one
substitute you would get and everybody
would try to [__] with her and she'd be
like sit down or you were out you were
going and you're like oh I can't [__]
with her there's a real moment though
when she said she was gonna try to
Wrangle you guys where I saw all of the
hairs on your right next year at the
idea
I don't think I do Wrangle you guys
though no I I it's not I want to talk
about the episodes
well that's just because I I like
talking about the episodes it's not
because I think the podcast is better
when we do it's just this is my
opportunity to grill you guys so I'm not
personally gonna pass that up I think
it's good to have the questions too
because sometimes I'll watch an episode
and be like I don't know exactly what to
talk about like I kind of want somebody
to ask me questions as opposed to just
bringing stuff up randomly well good
news I have some today let's do it did
you talk about do you want to talk about
that sir I do I I found it very funny or
is anyone coming in hot do any any I'm
not coming in cold coming in cold happy
but cold have you eaten enough today are
you are you physically not a physically
cold
I'm coming in I'm coming in in a good
mood I got up very early I did a radio
show in Philadelphia the Preston and
Steve show we're all aware of Preston
and Steve
of the podcast the live Sunny podcast
tour dude I'm going to be doing I'm very
excited about that yes
playing Radio City Music Hall in New
York City yeah I mean that is and the
venue in Philly is huge right I'm going
to tell you that the the the the the if
any we're playing in Philadelphia means
way more to me personally yeah City
Music Hall okay I have never I would say
that I have been to the Mann Music
Center which is where we're playing
um no less than and I'm not exaggerating
25 times okay I have never been inside
the Mann Music Center oh it was one of
those places where hang and score a bag
of mushrooms yes yes it was one of those
places in high school uh where uh the
The Allman Brothers would be playing or
um the uh heart maybe
[__] it hey with the heart
um no Steve wait what's the uh who sings
The Joker Steve Miller man you know like
that period of time yeah it was classic
rock and they were it was Yacht Rock and
they were kind of coming but you
wouldn't go to the concert you would
just go to to the parking lot
and it would be where high school kids
could find kegs of beer it was also a
place where you could find whippets sure
and apparently according to President
Steve this morning the Whippet Market is
Bowman is it people are still doing
whippets
real bad for the brain yeah yeah whip it
real whipping it real bad yeah now I'm
hoping there won't be any whippets in
the parking lot of the Always Sunny I
guarantee there will be somebody
somewhere has gotta whip it um speaking
of Philly though the I-95 collapse do
you have a lot of your friends texting
about that your like group sure did row
collapsed a whole highway a whole
highway that's crazy what because uh
tanker like ignited below it
and the fire collapsed the highway above
it the whole I-95 and there was a great
video which I'll probably put in the
podcast of uh local news of a guy
talking about having heard the I-95
collapsing and he's got that accent and
it is yes we're just watching it now
because we could we could talk about it
we could talk about it I'll see Rob
Roselle sent it to us I was sent that
exact clip by no less than 10 people
dude so I was passed out and I woke up
to nothing but text messages phone calls
I had no idea what was going on now I
got dressed I came out I looked down and
I smell like a smoky smell and I'm like
damn dude so
it's crazy when you came out and saw it
did you know what was happening yet or
did it just look like well no so I got
all those text messages screenshots I'm
like everybody's like yo where's this at
like nobody had like a direct like
location so I was like look out my
window I see a bunch of cops I'm like
bro that's right by my apartment so so
when did you figure out and realize that
the freeway collapsed the Northbound
side oh dude I was passed out when that
happened passed out
passed out I'll know what's going on
dude I was pissed why would you why
would you lead with that you're talking
to the news
you're talking to the news you know your
mom's gonna see this your friends are
all going to see it which is maybe why
you say it but you lead with
I was passed out passed out this is just
facts he's just stating facts you know
there's no filter to it also swearing on
the news
you can really hear the accent on saw
because they put like an owl at the end
of it it's like uh yeah something about
that Philly accent really
tickles the imagination it's confounding
it's it is the strangest it really is to
this day one of the strangest accents
it's like a Boston accent slammed with
the Deep South mixed with England
Australia and Australia there's some
Australia Australia and just like a
weird Bond villain yeah it sounds it
sounds fake like yeah you know what I
mean like if you'd never heard that
accent before and didn't know what it
was and somebody was doing it you'd be
like oh somebody's doing like a really
bad New York accent or well you remember
like when we first started the show when
we were debating like
do we do we do the accents or not and
we're like people won't know I don't
know what the [__] we're doing they're
gonna be like we just we chose specific
words and we'll just do it for those
words
yeah yeah he was he was messing around
with a lot in when he first came in in
the second he ramped it up this year a
little bit I noticed yeah suddenly
decided his character has a Philly
accent I do really want to talk about
this episode so shall we just should we
jump in mac and Charlie write a movie
yeah dude first of all Danny is doing
the accent a little bit in in this
episode but like the thing that jumped
out at me most was him why are you
rubbing on that phone why you rubbing on
it let me rub it let me rub on it
why are you rubbing on the phone let me
rub on me what are you doing hey hey
Frank get your greasy fat sausage
fingers off my touch screen phone this
thing's new my fingers are not greasy uh
you have Forest forces links and your
pocket right now yeah but I don't touch
the sausage links why should I do that
when I can let my shirt do the work
watch
um no touching oh God no animal that was
a Roselle joke totally I remember that
was a rose I remember that was a Roselle
line but also
just the the context that it was
an absurd thing that Dennis was looking
at his phone that much
and how sad it is that we now live in a
culture where we're all guilty of sort
of acting like you're acting in that
episode but in that episode it's a joke
that you're this disengaged
and now we are also engaged with that
device that I would also like to point
out horrible thing sad so that phone and
I remember this uh this was like a year
after a year or and change after
no actually I think it was like almost
two years after the iPhone had first
come out on the market
and blackberry
available for rent rental now uh had uh
had just come out with the Blackberry
Storm which was the phone that that
really destroyed it was gonna take the
World by storm yeah and boy it sure did
not they rushed it to Market and uh and
I remember actually I was like I was
wondering it was like why didn't we I
think I can't remember why we had a
Blackberry Storm instead of an iPhone I
think I think I can guess yeah apple was
like what yeah no no thank you no and
blackberry
yes please yes please yes please
you'll hold it never seen yes
and I do remember I do remember messing
around with the phone because I was
curious about it and I was so I was like
this is so weird like the whole screen
clicked
you know because the whole concept
behind the phone was it's not going to
be an iPhone because it'll be a touch
screen but it'll still have that
Blackberry click so when you press the
screen one of those the whole screen
would click
and it was
that piece of [__] yeah it's terrible
it's really glitchy it was really slow
it was very laggy
and not anything like the movie by the
same name which moves very quickly yeah
and yeah uh but but yeah I remember that
it was it was a Blackberry Storm and I
remember thinking like this is not a not
a great not a great phone
um but yeah but it was after I mean
touch screen phones had just come out so
it was just becoming a thing
to be able to like
you know be on your phone at all times
and not be a businessman just you guys
remember this because I don't remember
this like why
why did we go with that storyline for
your character right the disengage that
is very funny you know that we're
pitching in the movie and you're half
engaged and then you do finally get
engaged to talk about the penetration
which I thought was hilarious but like
but but do you like do you remember like
why like why we when would that sort of
that you needed the twist at the end
that he had been typing up yeah I mean I
think I think we were probably just
talking about in the room the fact that
like now with because the iPhone again
had been out for about a year and a half
or something like that and I think it
was becoming very clear that people were
just like you know even more glued to
their phones than they ever had been
that was a funny car it's a new kind of
funny thing to bring up but also you
know when we're in the right in the
writers room and we're like okay well
it'd be funny if these characters write
a movie okay who are the the dumbest
people to write the movie okay probably
it's Mac and Charlie we know Dee would
want to be in the movie we could see
Frank wanting to be an agent I'm like
okay Dennis Dennis like what you know
okay we figure out these two this
pairing this pairing now what are we
gonna do with Mac okay what's Matt gonna
do um it might have been there's just
that it should have been yeah this one
had the
uh what you know for whatever reason I I
can't remember why but like I don't know
why but very often times we don't send
you two off to to undraft just the two
of you yeah this was a and I remember
this Danny Howerton joint yeah I
remember yeah I remember I remember us
writing this together actually
um
and I remember it it being fun and yeah
I don't know why we don't do it more
often I remember I usually I have a
member of you guys coming back with a
draft and be like oh this is a lot of
fun like all the conversations about
what the movie's about yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah exactly yeah no it was fun and
I I remember thinking the concept of
like
I think when we hit on
that Dennis the fact that he's
disengaged is what makes him
um appealing as as an actor was funny to
us as kind of an inside joke is like
that kind of thing of like
you have to show this
there's this weird thing when you go
into auditions as an actor like if they
get the sense that you really want the
part there's something that kind of
turns people off about that even though
you should want the actor who worked the
hardest who wants the part the most
payment has a phrase for that yeah what
is the payment sexy indifference yeah
it's true it's true like if it's
something in every capacity it works in
every Works in every interpersonal
relationship that you have you know I
think I think that's why I I've always
that that's part of the reason why I
think Australians do so well in
auditions because I think they have that
kind of sexy indifference they're just
like
it doesn't feel like there are that many
it feels like a lot of them are just
like they're just rough wild crazy
people who come into who are just like
acting because it's like yeah I thought
it'd be fun you know just kind of guy
for it and just see what happens
[Music]
you know but it's almost like they don't
really give a [__] about it's just kind
of like something that they're doing
that day it's like doing the audition
come on now it's funny
it's no longer a continent
Oceana is not my my son is like big into
geography these days and uh they call
that whole region Oceana Oceana oh so
it's so it's Australia New Zealand yeah
and both answers are correct if you if
you say Australia you will get the you
will get you'll get the points you'll
get the points and if you say Oceana you
will also get the points okay well
where are we on the continent aspect of
it that's what it's a part of that
that's where we are that's where we're
at that the Oceana is is now the
continent but if you say Australia I
didn't see what you're saying before
clearly
he's still on the left side of the road
in Ireland yeah
sometimes I I don't know what you guys
are talking about
[Music]
okay as you know we give you the raw
unfiltered feed here on the podcast we
will always tell you how we really feel
and go to war over what we believe in
and right now we're
our story's new wash cleansing cream is
like shampoo but it's actually good for
your hair it's a first of its kind
custom formula that cleans conditions
detangles and restores hair without the
harsh Foams and damaging detergents
found in traditional shampoos so break
the wheel new wash gives you your best
hair day every day it gives you more
time in between washes never over cleans
and prevents color from fading you know
what's cool is a hair story has now come
up with two new formulas the new new
wash deep for deeper cleansing and new
wash rich
for even more moisture furthermore
shampoo is just really bad for the
environment what new wash is 100
biodegradable comes in 100 recyclable
pouch packaging and is part of one
percent for the planet donating one
percent of eight ounce new wash sales to
water related issues plus they offer a
subscription so you can set it forget
about it and keep the Good Hair Days
coming you don't want your hair looking
small man try new wash by going to
hairstory.com promo code sunny and have
your best hair day every day just like
Glenn new wash is the best way to wash
your hair visit hairstory.com promo code
Sunny to learn more enjoy 20 exclusive
savings when you use the code sunny at
hairstory.com at checkout
foreign
I really have to say I love this episode
because I think my favorite Sunny
episodes are where the stakes are
self-generated from within the gang
um like Dee comes in with this acting
job that she has but the whole Stakes of
that scene where Mac and Charlie are
pitching you the movie is kind of
self-created like Frank just says that
Dennis is a producer and then you guys
are pitching to him with the like
Earnest need like he can do something if
you if you sell him this movie and it
all kind of is like self-generated
within and never kind of breaks outside
of the gang which I think is always like
really funny because you totally believe
you all believe the steak like you and
like mac and Charlie are just so like
okay this is our one shot and you're
like you live with this guy I mean you
talk to him every single day
and an agent is great I would just like
to say to the audience out there that's
that's accurate in Hollywood there are
so many people that walk around the city
just show up and they tell people their
producers and the next thing you know
people are pitching to them and I don't
know what they do I don't know what
these people do
think of all the people that you know
who call themselves producers who don't
produce anything uh that's a good grift
for the sake of not going crazy I'm I'm
going to strongly agree with you
yeah there's some
yeah just some suspect producers out
there for sure
it is true though that you can you could
you could just step into a room and be
like I'm a producer you know and and you
know where I see it a lot too is when
people have production companies yeah
I've got a production company and then
you go on like you know IMDb Pro and
you're like you know because some guy
handed you a card and you're like oh
what is this what have they done nothing
I was just in Philadelphia uh for an
event and I was talking to many people
outside of our industry which is always
fun because we live in this bubble where
everybody we know Works in some capacity
or lives with or is we're we're very
close to everybody uh or so many people
that work in this in this industry and
to talk to people outside of it they'll
ask questions
um like what is a producer like what
does a producer actually do it's a tough
question it's a tough question to answer
because
there's so many there's so many
different jobs that fall under that
umbrella and one of which is nothing
yeah the answer is nothing yeah I don't
do anything I have a name I have a name
that they put up there and then they pay
me for that but I don't produce anything
yeah they at one point did and now they
just put their name on it and that's it
like when someone's good at it it's an
incredible asset you aren't actually
making something yeah you're really
making something you're making sure it
it happens it happens on schedule you're
making sure it gets seen you're guiding
it creatively
um
and then there are the people who sort
of
are able to like claw onto something and
then put their name on a thing and do
you think the producer's guild does try
to
um does try to protect for that a little
bit like on Films
you can't get the title of producer you
can get like you know associate producer
or co-producer or executive producer on
a film
without having to to go through as many
steps as I think you have to go through
for this is from what I understand from
talking to Jill about this because this
is what she does but like you have to go
through a lot more steps to to get that
big p producer title on a film and it's
also different in film and television
right like the big the best title the
best producer title you can get on a
film is producer the best producer title
you can get on a TV show is executive
producer I don't know why yeah that's
all because executive producer doesn't
mean as much on a film as it does
on a TV show but the average person
probably just has does not know that at
all
I don't know it's a tough thing to gauge
what it is within a project and what it
does to make it better or make it exist
um and we all know because just from
having worked with both the producers
that
are essential to the success of a
project and then the ones that are able
to kind of just be in the way or the
ones that actively make it more
difficult to succeed it is amazing how
often you'll see you know I'll see you
a movie you know that Ryan did and I'll
see somebody's name on there who I
recognize and then I'll text them and
say oh I know that person or I work with
that person
um how did you find that experience and
he was like never met that person before
never saw that person had nothing to do
with the making of that movie but even
I'm
even I'm watching it and and it tricks
me into believing that they had
something to do with the movie but they
didn't oh yeah yeah it's it's kind of a
it it it's it's it's kind of insulting
to the people who really are the kind of
producers who are there on set every
single day standing behind the you know
behind the monitors and are really
involved and are there on a daily hourly
basis like solving problems as they come
up which are of which there are a
zillion on a movie set like yeah it's
constant problem solving and trying to
protect the director and and being a uh
in between the studio and the director
and navigating those two it's an
extraordinarily difficult job for the
people who do it who are there on set
like doing like really doing the job of
research I've done a lot of projects
with John Rickard uh and John Ricard now
works with Peter Safran and they uh
I think Peter now runs DC with um uh
James both James but John is a real
producer you know John like mate is
making things happen every day and
making sure that that the movie happens
and and then making sure that the movie
gets seen and and gets out to an
audience and yeah there are a million
things coming at you left and right that
are either gonna compromise or ruin
um but then I've worked with people you
know or had people seen people get their
name on a project at the 11th Hour who
really had nothing to do with it except
maybe Were Somehow involved in the sale
or the distribution of something yeah
that you're like oh wow that's a should
be a different title for that do you
guys remember if this episode came out
of like
M Night Shyamalan talking about that and
wanted to talk about like movies with
twists and stuff or more out of like uh
wanting to skewer sort of Hollywood
because the the show has occasionally
ventured into some like Hollywood
territory you know with the Thunder guns
and like the Lethal Weapon movies and
like the characters are dancing around
wanting to be like in the industry do
you remember like how that kind of I
think it was that
our characters like what they would
think a good movie was and what that was
fertile ground for a really funny comedy
just there what their pitch was about a
guy who smells crime like okay we know
that's gonna be funny right with M night
I think it was just that he was a famous
successful guy from Philly yeah who
makes all his movies in Philly who makes
all of his movies in Philly so we're
like well the characters could
potentially have access to them yeah
yeah and they would be aware of him do
you remember where Dolph Lundgren
specifically like why you centered on
Dolph Lundgren as uh then that carried
through is sunny like that being your
sort of favorite actions I think
probably just because Rocky IV was such
an iconic movie uh at the time and then
certainly for these characters
and we'd already established it as that
yeah I mean we started talking about
that uh in season two here's Sunny fan
fiction that might be fun to kind of
think about by the time we were pitching
this movie
had we already shot Lethal Weapon seven
our characters oh oh no you know yeah
in the timeline in the time yes probably
yeah well because because that doesn't
that uh oh no not seven uh I think the
first one we did was what Lethal Weapon
five six six I can't even I don't
remember but whatever the first one is
you're talking about right yeah yeah I I
imagine it was because I think we did
the first Lethal Weapon episode
season six didn't we you know what would
be fun fun to do maybe waiting for a fan
to do this is this actually seems like
something Meg would love to do is to
build a sunny chronology yeah from from
birth until like where we stand now
because we play so many things out of
timeline and we talk back to the good
old days of when this might have
happened or when this happens
like we met Smitty throwing rocks at
trains you know where we met I would
think yes what years that either they
had already shot Lethal Weapon I think
they probably need the weapons a six or
they shot it immediately after this
whole episode of D being in here's the
second swing and we're like yeah you
know what we should make a movie a
sequel would be easier
yeah we don't have to come up with it
like wholesale yeah
um I think that in this episode my two
favorite scenes are the one of uh Mac
and Charlie brainstorming the idea for
the movie it's just so funny and it
really captures
that feeling in a writer's room where
you feel like you get on a roll and then
you're all like firing and people are
throwing up yes and you're getting so
excited about it and then that one
person goes a little too far and you're
like wow you're like who's gonna put it
for me watching that to be like this
kind of does mirror our relationship
where how many times have we been in a
room kind of pitching ideas and getting
each other excited about an idea like
many many times for many many years we
both have the realization at the same
time we've got something here and we've
got to get it on paper yeah
because I want the movie to be big right
you know and like a box office Smash and
we want to put like a lot of meat in the
seats you know yeah you know what I'm
thinking dude you know what I'm thinking
something that's happened in Hollywood
that's like pretty cool they take an
underrated actor right whose career is
in a slump and then they make him a star
again oh that is awesome right yeah yeah
let's do that yeah so who is the most
underrated actor of all time it's Dolph
Lundgren correct why well because of his
uh spiky hair his ice cold demeanor and
his big muscles absolutely okay all
right all right so we have our actor
okay that's great now we need a really
great role for him oh you know what I
was thinking scientists are cool what if
he's a scientist okay okay a muscular
scientist I'm into that right as long as
we don't cover up that body with a lab
coat bro dude he's wearing like a hot
mesh tank top I like that now does he
like fight crime or something yeah yeah
he fights crime uh with his brain and
his brawn
should we be writing this down all right
but it also I think mirrors like you
seem to you know Charlie seems to be
like pure like creative kind of uh
output with no structure no filter
structure at all and then Mac is sort of
like well you know let's put that into
something sheer Madness
the other great one is the pitch the
pitch scene where where they are then
pitching to Dennis there that is it that
yeah
that's [__] great the scene in the
you're talking about the scene in the
trailer in the trailer and Danny in that
scene is amazing too
all right you guys got 30 seconds blow
my mind
all right guys guys it's the prequel to
The Sixth Sense
imagine a super ripped super smart
scientist in a mesh tank top named
doctor
Dolph Lundgren no that's that's not his
name is he's played by Dolph Lundgren
but that's not the character no it could
be the character's name no that's
a doctor played by Dolph Lundgren named
Dolph Lundgren yeah that's confusing
that's more confusing than making up an
entirely new name for a person that's
gonna confuse people I'm taking it over
I'm taking over you are losing me okay
imagine a super smart ripped scientist
played by Dolph Lundgren who after a
terrible accident in his lap blows off
his nose after reconstructive surgery he
soon realizes that he smells something
that stinks
[Music]
[Applause]
but I think what makes it for me it's so
stupid but the crumpled papers that
you're all holding the like the loose
leaf paper that yeah it's just like it's
all a mess and you're holding on to it
well we got to get there's genius here
yeah and we just got to get somebody to
to put it in order to type it up yeah
type it up get it in order yeah it's
fine those two scenes for me
super funny Danny with the sausages in
the beginning great but yeah the episode
itself like wasn't my favorite like from
a structure like the story standpoint
um
but I don't know but it's funny it's
just funny it's just funny
and yeah that's that speech that we
wrote for for Dennis it's still I
remember it just was one of those things
where as an actor where you're just like
oh man
this is like this is exactly what I want
to do yeah I mean like you know you
forget those who have those moments
moments where you where you have a thing
and you you're like you have this moment
where you step outside of yourself or or
you you're able to reconnect with the
child inside you who wanted to become a
professional actor and go oh my God I
get to I get to deliver this speech like
this is so funny
now in terms of the story uh clearly
it's brilliant it's amazing and I like
it a lot brilliant idea but there is one
critical element that's missing it needs
a sexual punch-up we need to get a
female lead character in there that
Dolph can bang throughout the whole
movie yeah I kind of hate women though
oh I feel like they just slow action
movies down too right no Maxi you're
dead wrong on that you're dead wrong see
one of the problems with shyamalan's
movies is that they lack a certain
eroticism what if we were to bring an
incredibly hot but skeptical female lab
partner into the mix and then that way
whenever doll's not out busting heads
because he smelled crime he's back at
the lab performing outrageous sexual
experiments on her supple young body
now here's the Twist and there is a
twist
we show it
we show all of it
because what's the one major thing
missing from all action movies these
days guys
full penetration
guys we're gonna show full penetration
and we're gonna show a lot of it and we
were talking you know graphic scenes of
Dolph Lundgren really going to town on
this hot young lap Tech from behind 69
anal vaginal cowgirl reverse cowgirl all
the hits all the big ones all the good
ones and then he smells crime again he's
out busting heads then he's back to the
lab for some more full penetration he
smells crime back to the lab full
penetration crime penetration Crime full
penetration crime penetration and this
goes on and on and back and forth for 90
or so minutes until the movie just sort
of ends
and then it became a part of our
everyday vernacular yeah the end of the
end of it yeah that it just sort of goes
on and on that's what it was wrong ends
which is I I believe how people would
think of a movie you know or TV show or
any story it's somebody who doesn't you
know there's a beginning there's a
middle a bunch of things happen I mean
we actually we set that up in the very
beginning we're just telling a series of
events that happen and then it ends and
that's the story yeah yeah yeah but it's
the way you tell it and then you say the
way you told it was by far the worst
part
but also within that big speech I also
love it it's just such a silly little
thing but you say
um all the hits all the best ones all
the big ones all the big ones
yeah all the big moves yeah all the all
the main sex moves
also Charlie thinking the twist of uh
the Sixth Sense is that that guy in the
hairpiece was Bruce Willis yeah
that was a joke I remember being in
there from the original outline like all
the way like yes Charlie Charlie watched
The Sixth Sense not knowing that that
was Bruce Willis because he had hair
because he had hair because he had hair
so he didn't know that was Bruce Willis
and then McLean doesn't have that much
hair no yeah exactly and then he sees
the movie and he realizes at the end
he's like oh my God that's Bruce Willis
and he thinks that's but it was just
because that's the that was when he
realized that it was Bruce Willis
instead instead instead of that guy you
know who else is amazing and that is
Donnie Wahlberg yeah yes can we give it
up for Donnie Wahlberg who is incredible
in that film give it up all right he had
the right stuff
yeah he's great in that he's great in
that movie that movie
I haven't watched that movie in a long
time I should rewatch them in my head
well yeah it's fine I said I said Donny
had the right stuff yeah yeah the right
stuff I get it okay
so you got it you just didn't care you
just didn't care for it
um it's fine yeah it was fine it was
fine
yeah no it was a joke and it was fine it
was fine it wasn't worth slowing down
oh
God
uh you guys the Always Sunny podcast is
sponsored by betterhelp oh sorry I
haven't been uh I'm tired I haven't been
uh sleeping well lately have you not
everything okay I mean yeah I I thought
so at least I just haven't been able to
fall asleep and uh none of my tried and
true uh sleep aids are working you know
what Charlie honestly that I I I'm
having a little bit of a sleep problem
myself lately I'm just you know every
time I lay down I'm just my mind is
spinning I can't shut it off you know I
mean so I tell you there's some nights I
can't I honestly can't sleep at all have
you tried the tasty Trio the tasty Trio
uh I have cat food glue beer okay but I
think I'd prefer to get to the root of
the problem okay well it sounds like a
great opportunity for you both to try
better help better help is an online
therapy service designed to be flexible
affordable and convenient to your
schedule day or night really I can use
better help when I'm up in the middle of
the night sure you can message your
therapist on betterhelp whenever you
want to and they'll get back to you as
soon as they can I personally have used
better help before and it helped me a
lot for um what I was going through then
did you ever message them at 3am
I'm gonna plead the fifth on that well
if you are thinking about it give it a
try just go online and fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist plus you could switch
therapists at any time at no additional
cost so go ahead and let therapy be your
map with better help visit
betterhelp.com sunny today to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash sunny
um I think my favorite line in this
episode is very small but in the library
scene where you guys are looking for
somebody to type up your script for you
and you point out that older lady and
then Charlie says I don't care for her
demographic I find them judgmental
judgments was that in the script or did
you just have an extra that day no idea
I mean it sounds like it was scripted
like scripted yeah no it must have been
because we feature of the ladies so yeah
okay she's a featured extra it is
Mac hating women was not in the script
that was that I remember that I remember
that specifically well because your
reaction to it is like you're expecting
him to say something that you're 100 on
board with good he starts to say
something you've got the pen in your
hand and you're pointing to him you're
like and then he says that and you're
like
I think the line was something like
women always ruin action movies yeah
yeah they slow down movies which I
follow up with but yeah I led with I
kind of hate women though yeah yeah yeah
I think yeah
it's starting to go that way with your
character right around there yeah we
planted a flag right there yeah yeah at
the time it didn't it didn't have as
much significance as it was just pure
misogyny yes just pure misogyny yeah
that was like that was just massaging
and then from there you know you're here
you hadn't looked into why he hates
women yes exactly exactly and and but so
it's like a complete lack of awareness
as to how offensive that could be to
some people also and how you deliver it
it's just kind of like I kind of hate
women though yeah but you know because
you guys get it you got you get it you
guys hate women too yeah so you know can
we not yeah uh I mean the the lack of a
cell phone reflection for all the
characters is speaking of hating women
Caitlyn
folks wait the way that we would shoot
that now would be completely different
at the time we we didn't even think
about the fact that there was four or
five different scenes in four different
locations with her wearing all of that
make up that blood
so she put it on in the morning and then
had to shoot all of and had to wear it
all day like you can't even go sit in a
chair without sticking with everything
right now we would shoot all of her
stuff in a short amount of time it's
just so sticky and like yeah you sit
down to have lunch and you're just like
solidify and then you made her go face
down on like a conqueror that was a
producer knowing it would be cheaper to
get all the shots in that location that
day and us still being young enough to
let the producer get away with that
just a second I'm gonna produce I don't
care if you're sticky all day we're
gonna get this this thing done in the
most efficient and the most costly it's
possible do you guys know the uh Lex
Medlin played the A.D he's dealing with
to was he like a friend of yours no I
think that was just an audition
situation yeah I mean I was so good in
that episode he's fantastic but
everybody else in the crew it was fun uh
did you notice that the rest of the crew
that was standing around was our action
and I was and I was trying to think if I
could remember
a lot of their names because it was
people from years ago so there's a whole
lineup at some point behind them oh
really including the the camera guy
I saw the KO lighting thing in the back
of the oh my God yeah so uh KO is our
our gaffer and uh yeah his dad
uh was a he was the dad
Keith orifice and his son Jared orifice
yeah the orifice family the orifice
family
um and his dad passed away during the
run of the show so he's like did you
want to comment on that no I just never
heard it last name of orifice before a
new new one for me it's a new orifice
you wonder like where that because they
didn't a lot of last names that came
from like what you did for a living you
know what I mean like where did orifice
come from you know what I mean like what
did that guy what did he what did his
ancestors do for a living that they had
that it was probably some beautiful name
from like another country
[Laughter]
[Applause]
just swim up on the beach
you know
here's one little like creative cheat
that we've done several times
um
where when you start to see the movie
within the movie It's like a fully
produced movie yeah hearing like the
music and the score and the like machine
gun fire
what the hell are you doing be curious
about seeing it without that
what do you mean seeing it more like it
was from the Monitor and you're not
hearing the the movie score uh-huh but I
think because you don't have like
character lines you don't have like
dialogue comedically it feels like she's
ruining more yes when it's like yes yes
I think that's what it is when she's
when she's ruining it it's funnier if
she's ruining it as you're watching I
think too because the shot itself
we hadn't scripted anything for it right
so it's just like you know we let
Randall kind of probably come up with
what it was and it was just you know
guys walking with some machine guns and
it probably in the editing room was like
a little boring to be like well nothing
much is happening so like you said she's
not ruining much versus like if it had
been like an intense dialogue scene or
something and the camera went by the
people like talking and then she's
saying brains in the shot you know but
Dennis but it was also but that was also
what was supposed to be funny about it
too is just like this is just a second
unit oh yeah that's right right this
isn't even that important it's supposed
to be an easy shot to get yeah it's just
a quick shot where we're showing all
these poor people they're dead they're
dead bodies like that's that's all it
really is and then she's just ruining
everything you guys ever ruined a scene
by having your phone ring in the middle
of it
I know what Glenn's phone rang earlier
today yeah yeah yeah and it was so loud
I never turned around I mean I've seen
it happen a million times but you can
see there you could probably do a super
cut of the amount of times that you'll
see one of us like in the middle of a
scene sunny and we just like reach out
to our pocket and then yeah
click it describe
so like you're in the middle of the
scene and you just like you know keep
going with the scene that's a real Pro
movie
you could probably you could probably
scour movies and TV shows and find that
happening yeah that'd be a fun super cut
actually if somebody could really that
would take a lot of work that's that's
something for the AI to find that's
something for the AI right that's the
kind of thing that AI is going to be
really good for as far as I'm concerned
is like you know scouring the internet
for for moments like that you know
something that a human being just could
never possibly have the patience to do I
don't think God I hope not if you got
that kind of time on your hands wow I'm
looking at the timetable and we we we
have not too long left so I feel like we
should and this should just sort of end
uh
you want to argue did you want to talk
about over hydration yeah
let's talk about over hydration because
I got into I got I was I was excited to
come to the podcast because I said to
Caitlin Glenn and I got into a fight
last time and I still don't believe that
I've been heard
the following content has been edited
for time you're welcome
who are concerned with their hydration
are not drinking when they're thirsty
only they are forcing fluids because
they're they believe that they're
supposed to now I imagine I can only
imagine that part of viewers excited to
bring this up because you thought I was
going to have some sort of retort uh no
no where my mind went where my mind went
to was where I feel like the missing
piece of our of our argument maybe maybe
this was resolved I I don't really know
first of all I never remember thinking
reading hearing
and certainly not saying that coffee was
poison but if you say I said it I guess
maybe I did
well of course there's a limit to how
much water you can drink right if you
drink if if you start drinking water
right now and you don't stop you will
drown of course of course
I'm just trying to understand how you
can't see something but why do I care
about that I don't know
this back and forth has gone on for a
while I don't know what are what are we
trying to yeah right keep going back and
forth but how much water do you have to
drink to kill yourselves
I wonder how many times we can have this
conversation on the podcast and have it
remain interesting but why did I miss
you guys this has been great I do have
to wrap it up because we have time
constraints today and so uh
unfortunately this is where it has to
end oh with no satisfaction
satisfaction just uh Cliff maybe a
cliffhanger I don't know maybe that's
good we'll be back to talk more about
let's not but we disagree
thank you
[Applause]